Elabora la gráfica de la ecuación lineal
"5x" más "2y" igual a 20.
Básicamente queremos graficar la recta
que es el conjunto de coordenadas el conjunto de puntos "x", "y" que cumplen con esta ecuación lineal.
Para esto simplemente vamos a elaborar una tabla,
con valores de "x" y los valores de "y" correspondientes que cumplen con esta relación
para facilitar esto voy a despejar a "y" de la ecuación
y así fácilmente dados los valores de "x"
obtendremos los valores de "y"
Tenemos entonces "5x" más "2y" igual a 20
queremos despejar "y" así es que vamos a restar
"5x" ambos lados de la ecuación
"-5x" del lado izquierdo y
"-5x" del lado derecho
estos términos se cancelan
nos quedan "2y" del lado izquierdo
y del lado derecho nos queda 20 menos "5x"
ahora vamos a dividir entre 2,
ambos lados de la ecuación
dividimos entre 2 el lado izquierdo
y entre 2 el lado derecho
estos términos se van,
nos queda "y" del lado izquierdo
y del lado derecho podríamos dejarlo  ya así,
sería más fácil calcularlo
pero bueno vamos a simplificarlo,
entonces sería 20 entre 2 es igual a 10
menos 52 es 5/2 de"x"
ahora sí ya podemos ir dando valores de "x" obtener los valores de "y" y simplemente graficarlos...
déjame hacer esto en un color distinto...
voy a agarrar éste
que es otro tono de amarillo...
tenemos entonces valores para "x" y...
valores para "y"
empecemos con "x" igual a 0
podría ser cualquier valor pero con "x" igual a 0
es más fácil calcular el valor de "y"
con "x" igual a 0 ¿cuánto vale "y"?
"y" va a ser igual a 10
menos 5/2 de 0
y esto va a ser igual, 5/2 de 0 es 0
y nos queda "y" igual a 10
así es que cuando "x" vale 0...
cuando "x" vale 0 "y" vale 10,
hemos obtenido el punto 0,10
vamos a graficarlo
"x" igual a 0
es justo en el centro del eje "x"
y 10 para la coordenada en "y"
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10
0, 10 es este punto de aquí
0, 10
encontremos otro punto.
Vamos a agarrar para "x" igual a 2
voy a agarrar múltiplos de 2
para que esto se simplifique en un número entero
entonces para "x" igual a 2,
"y" va a ser igual a 10
menos 5/2 de 2,
aquí tenemos 2 en el denominador
y 2 en el numerador se simplifican
y nos queda simplemente 10 menos  5.
"y" es igual a 5
es decir,
hemos hallado el punto 2, 5
2 para la "x",
5 para la "y"
vamos a graficarlo entonces
tenemos 2 para la "x" 1, 2
justo aquí
y "y" igual 5 hacia arriba
1, 2, 3, 4, 5
este es el punto 2, 5.
Y para graficar una recta sólo necesitamos 2 puntos
usando una regla, podemos trazar la recta
que pasa a través de estos dos puntos
si la trazamos con cuidado cada punto
en esa línea satisface esta relación.
Simplemente para practicar, obtendré más puntos.
Haciendo ahora "x" igual a 4
obtenemos que
"y" es igual a 10 menos 5/2 de 4
¿y esto a que es igual?
bueno, aquí podemos simplificar
tenemos 2 en el denominador,
4 en el numerador, este 2...
2 entre 2 es igual a 1
4 entre 2 es igual a 2
y nos queda entonces 10 menos 5 por 2,
5 por 2 es 10, 10 menos 10 es igual a 0
hemos obtenido el punto 4, 0
Tenemos entonces para "x"
1, 2, 3, 4,
4 para "x"
y "y" igual a 0, el punto está sobre el eje "x"
este es el punto 4, 0
y puedo obtener otros puntos,
puedes hacerlo por tu cuenta si lo deseas
pero con estos 3 puntos es más que suficiente, de hecho con sólo dos puntos bastaba para trazar la recta.
Así es que déjame graficarla,
para esto voy a usar el blanco,
la línea se verá... la línea se verá
algo como esto
la línea se verá
algo más o menos como esto
esta es la apariencia de la línea,
y podría extenderla a ambas direcciones.
Y aquí la tienes,
esta es la gráfica de la ecuación lineal.
Déjame resaltar la línea me parece
que me quedó un poco delgada,
la voy a resaltar para que puedas ver más claramente
la gráfica de esta recta.